if you don't get married before the age
of 25 you cannot be a traditional woman
I know I know please take it in female
influencers take it in I I'm sorry all
right guys so I've gotten in some hot
water because I've been talking about
how basically everything is fabulous now
before I start this video I would like
to say that 95 of women and just people
in general have been influenced by
feminism so am I in no way saying this
is you this I am in no way saying this
makes you a bad person I am in no way
saying you don't have the right to do
this I am just pointing out this is
feminism so what I noticed was there is
a trend of the Trad wife and I see this
on like Twitter Instagram whatever now
I'd like to start off by saying because
I know everybody's gonna say this I
don't consider myself to be the trader
right you know because all right and
I'll tell you why because I started
thinking about this what is a
traditional wife like when it goes is
down to the Bare Bones it means that
family over everything family over
career family over pretty much
everything the ideal Trad wife is a
woman that wants to have as many kids as
possible and what I realized is that if
you don't get married before the age of
25 you cannot be a traditional woman I
know I know please take it in female
influencers take it in I I'm sorry I'm
sorry but it's not in the cards for us
and I'll tell you why because a
traditional wife believes that family is
more important to spend her primary
reproductive years over a career over
anything really now all right so I made
this is like our our fertility this is
rough I'm not I'm not a doctor or
whatever but this is just a rough 35
geriatric pregnancy so I just put down
here bad 35. so essentially if you spent
the ages before 25 working a job that's
feminism that's what the elites want on
it if you have two kids that's feminism
why is having two kids feminist because
the elites the feminists want you to
spend your reproductive years working
instead of raising a family I'm not
saying I'm not saying you're a bad
person if you chose to do this but when
you think about it how would you get two
kids how if you're fertile from the age
of 16 to the age of 35. that's 20 years
how would you get two kids without birth
control how would you get kids without
push two kids without pushing off Merit
and two kids or less is a below is below
the replace therefore that is what
they're trying to do they're trying to
make us have as few kids as possible in
the name of equality in the name of
ruining everything now again please
ladies so what'll happen is a lot of us
will think we have this traditional wife
to look up because the woman got married
she's a housewife whatever but half the
time she doesn't believe in obeying her
husband if you you say your husband
doesn't need to ask you to make
decisions bam craziness um she still
uses feminist words so her whenever you
talk about submission or you hold a
woman accountable there's always some
way she's gonna blame the men there's
always going to be some abusive men
which kind of goes back to this like
feminist idea that women can do no wrong
we are Queens we are angels if we do
anything wrong it's probably the fault
of the men a lot of times even in church
they demonize male sin but do not
demonize females so you always hear
about how women can leave a marriage a
husband cheats but I have never heard
the church say non-virgin women are not
qualified for marriage now I know maybe
you're like okay 95 percent of chicks
are not virgins on their wedding day and
I think that's a fair enough point but
my whole point is this all is feminism
they also put therapy is feminist a
feminists want to get into your family
so they'll say oh in order to save the
marriage you need to go to therapy when
in the past we used to go to our
grandparents our parents for advice but
now their whole ideas let's Outsource
the family let's make the state the
family that is feminine schools you know
the moms used to be really involved in
teaching their kids now you send the
kids to the state which we all know all
of these institutions all of these um
all of these institutions are run by
feminists this is back my last wife the
school the sports work it's all feminist
now again never said anyone's a bad
person whatever this is just observing
the society okay ladies please stay with
me the other thing you'll notice with a
lot of like a lot of them I guess Trad
wives or like from the conservative and
the left too like this is on both sides
but you'll get feminist words sexual
assault
narcissist misogynist these are all
feminist words because they've
essentially go into all of our
institutions they got into our schools
they got into our churches they got into
the media and it's a no wonder that a
hundred years ago 85 percent of women
were virgins on their wedding days women
wearing white not being a virgin is
feminism saying that non-virgin women
are worthy of marriage is feminism now
I'm not necessarily like obviously as
women we're basically just children who
you can just put anything in front of us
and will believe I mean name one
housewife that's in the media but we
have cardi B Nicki Minaj Alex Cooper
from caller Daddy all of these women are
really living out what feminism wants
and even when you have a traditional
wife they usually have two kids they
usually got married over the age of 25.
um half the time they have their kids in
daycare or public schools which is all
feminists and if there's any problems in
their marriage they'll go to therapy
also feminine and again because what is
traditional traditional is family before
everything so you would never send your
kid to daycare or Nanny because fam
family comes first you would never send
your kid to sports where a team becomes
their family at least especially not the
women because the men are supposed to be
working yeah and so that's what I mean
when I say feminism is everywhere that's
what I mean when I say feminists have
infiltrated everything and definitely
infiltrated the family unit and that's
what I mean when I say you really cannot
be a traditional woman over the age of
25 because a traditional woman got
married first that was the most
important thing to her and she wasn't
too picky she didn't have all these
crazy standards she just found a guy
that wanted a family wanted to work and
had and started to have a family you
know don't shoot the messenger maybe I'm
crazy maybe I just make this [__] up I
don't know uh but let me know in the
comments what you guys think subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell I'll talk to you next time